we hear a lot about genius we're taught
to admire the minds of those infinite
baffling but astonishing geniuses like
Einstein Tolstoy or Picasso quite what
genius might actually be is left a
little vague
it's a code word for brilliant but
perhaps too otherworldly ever really to
fathom we're invited to stand in or at
the achievements of geniuses but also to
feel that their thought processes might
be quasi magical and that it's
ultimately simply mysterious how they
were ever able to come up with the ideas
they've had but there is a radically
different view suggested by a hugely
prescient quote from the 19th century
American genius Ralph Waldo Emerson the
quote runs like this in the minds of
geniuses we find once more our own
neglected thoughts what this tells us is
that the genius doesn't have different
kinds of thoughts from the rest of us
they simply take them more seriously we
ourselves will often have had our own
sketchy hesitant versions of their ideas
which is why their works can have such a
distinctive impression on us what they
present feels surprising and impressive
of course yet also obvious and right
once it's been pointed out the geniuses
are giving clear and powerful
articulation to notions that are already
familiar because we've been circling
them ourselves possibly for years
without quite ever being able to close
in on them properly genius can in the
sense be defined as paying closer
attention to our real thoughts and
feelings and being brave and tenacious
enough to hold on to them even when they
find no immediate echo in the world
beyond the reason why we disavow so much
of what passes through our minds is in
essence anxiety we kill off our most
promising thoughts for fear of seeming
strange to ourselves and others which
explains why small children are in their
own way so much more interesting than
the average adult they've not yet become
experts in what not to say or think but
when we censor and close down when we
take fright and try not to think it's
exactly the moment when the so-called
genius starts a take note of what's
happening within their mind we operate
with a false picture of genius when we
identify it too strongly with what's
exotic and utterly beyond us it's
something far more provocative than this
genius is what we all can be when we pay
careful attention to what's truly
passing through consciousness we all
have very similar and very able Minds
we're geniuses differ is in their more
robust inclinations to study them
properly we love bringing you these
films if you want to help us to keep
bringing you thoughtful content please
consider supporting us by visiting our
shop at the link on your screen now